investing boils down to risk and returns
let's talk money all we talk is money
all we talk is money
all we talk is money let's get right
into it with high risk invest and this
is the talk of the town this is rocking
out with your stock out here's a general
rule of thumb
the more memes you see about something
the riskier it is and at the top of the
list
is crypto yeah you got your save for
cryptos you got bitcoin
ethereum coinbase you want to give it a
go for the long term
go ahead but then you got your doge
coins and the moon coins
the get rich quick schemes of crypto if
you have to check it
every single day it's probably a risky
investment and if you're too embarrassed
to tell your parents you own it
it's definitely a risky investment and
we can't forget about these
mythical nfps which popped up out of
nowhere
which are like internet trading cards or
something then you got the day traders
they're buying
individual stocks they're staying up
late on reddit and they're hanging on
jim
cramer's every word bye-bye buy sell
sell sell you're in you're out it's red
it's green
it's enough to make you feel blue and
they're probably too young to buy
alcohol
but boy these prepubescent robin
hoodlums
can move markets you also got your
jordan belford wolf of wall street
penny stock savages you listen to me if
i put you in at seven and took you out
to 32
the only problem you'll have is that you
didn't buy
more buddy your only problem is you
believe the bona fide scam artist that
can't be trusted with lunch money
good luck with that and how about these
forex traders investing in worldwide
currencies
getting sizeable returns in exchange for
international fatigue
and premature balding then you got
commodities
wheat gold silver oil oh you're an oil
man i see
you're investing in opec but crude oil
fell to zero dollars a barrel during the
pandemic
and now you're out of gas and then
there's these complicated derivative
investing strategies
like options trading and futures
contract no
not that future no not that future
either
c it's complicated either way these are
high risk high-risk
high-stress paranoia-filled investments
every day is a different investment
we're up we're down we're all around
hold on
i gotta sell look
although it's fun and exciting this
should not be the majority of your
holdings
moving on to medium risk investments you
can't go wrong here these are the
stallions
in the investing horse race you got
mutual funds index funds etfs total
broad market funds
reits and blue chip stocks rewind that
if that was too fast
these investments are switzerland you're
neutral you're making money without
all the drama you're not quite in the
casino and you're also not in the
retirement home you're in the middle
you're diversified and you're betting on
big broad stocks
that traditionally provide a consistent
returns you're talking about etfs
index funds and mutual funds these are
the investing version of a mullet
business in the front but a party in the
back
it feels like a stock without all the
risk because it's a bunch of investments
bundled up
you're not biting into an apple you're
eating the whole fruit salad
why order the sirloin when you can buy
the whole cow
you can check it from time to time but
you're not checking twitter over the
volatility of an index fund you can rest
easy at night and still make healthy
returns
but beware of fees mutual funds are
always changing their positions
so they can charge more index funds are
like a lexus
elegant and reliable whereas mutual
funds are like a tesla
more expensive and always updating last
you got your low-risk
long-term old-man investments these are
your 401ks
iras roth ira 403b
and target date funds these are taxed
advantage
retirement accounts with the 401k you're
not paying
any taxes now and if your company is
providing a match
you better take it that's free money and
i'm not saying this to be clever it's
genuinely
free money with the roth ira you
pay taxes now but never have to worry
about taxes
down the road so this is what you do you
sign up you consistently contribute and
then you
set it and forget it don't touch it or
you'll pay a penalty
this is the opposite of day trading this
is decade trading it's all about time
in the market and not trying to time the
market you're using terms like
asset allocation stock versus bond mix
tracking and rebalancing now these
aren't exactly the hottest sexiest
investments
nobody's coming up to at a party and
giving you a hot tip
about a 401k account now you listen man
you want to get rich slow let me tell
you
you get to this 401k thing and you call
me crazy but you talked to me in about
30 40 years and you'll see
in 2055 we'll be chilling out a yacht in
the bahamas
nobody's having that talk but they
should
if you got a 401k you're not going to
impress your girlfriend but you will
impress your grandma and your gains will
sure as hell
impress your grandkids my two cents
start with a solid foundation start
building wealth then you can start
taking risks
the younger you are the more risks you
can take the older you are the last
thing you need to be is all in on
dogecoin
investing should be boring you want fun
hit the club
you want excitement get excited about
your career
building wealth is a marathon not a
sprint it's not about who can get rich
the quickest it's about who can stay
wealthy
the longest when it comes to investing
keep it simple
keep your costs low tune out the noise
and stay
the course and remember the best
investment you can make is
in yourself and after all this
if you're still not sure if you're ready
to invest save that money all we talk is
thanks for watching this video on the
three types of investing how you live
let me know below in the comments how
you're investing and as always
save that money all we talk is money all
we talk is money